in the last video we talked about how
parallax is the apparent change in
position of something based on your line
of sight and if you experience parallax
kind of in your everyday life if you
look outside of the car window while
it's moving you see that nearby objects
seem to be moving faster than faraway
objects so in the last video we measured
the apparent displacement of the star at
different points in the year relative to
straight up but you could also measure
it relative to things in the night sky
at that same time of year that same time
of day when think that don't appear to
be moving and they won't appear to be
moving because they're going to be way
way way farther away than this star over
here there might be other galaxies or
maybe even other clusters of galaxies or
who knows things that are not changing
in position so that's another option and
that's how another way to make sure that
you're looking at the right part of the
universe so you could measure relative
to straight up if you know based on the
time of year and the time of day that
you're looking at the same direction of
the universe or you could just find
things in the universe that are way far
back that their apparent position isn't
changing so just to visualize this again
I'll visualize it in a slightly
different way let's let's let's say this
is our let's say this is the night field
of vision this is the night let me
scroll to the right a little bit let's
say our night field of vision looks like
this and I'll do it in a dark color
because it's at night so our night field
of vision looks like this and let's say
that this right over here this right
over here is straight up this right here
is if we're just looking straight up in
the night sky and just to make the
convention and the last in the last
video I kind of changed our orientation
a little bit but I'll reorient us in
kind of a in kind of a traditional
orientation so if we make this North
this is south this will be West and then
this will be east so when we're looking
at the star in the summer what will what
will be look like well first of all the
Sun is just beginning to rise so if you
can think about it
this North this north direction we're
looking at the Sun from a we're looking
at the Earth from above so the North
will be the top of this sphere over here
and and so and the south will be the
bottom of this view the other side of
the sphere
that we're not seeing the East will be
this side this side of the sphere where
the Sun is just beginning to rise where
the Sun is just beginning to rise right
over there so what will be the apparent
position of this star well it's going to
be towards the east it's going to be
towards the direction that the Sun is
rising so this angle this angle right
over here is going to be right right
over there so this will be the angle
this will be this will be the angle
theta so this is in the summer and what
about the winter well in the winter too
in order to straight up in order for
straight up to be that same point in
time or that same direction of the
universe I should say then the Sun the
Sun will just be setting we're rotating
around that way so we're just going to
be clap capturing the last glimpse the
last glimpse of sunlight so in that
situation the Sun is going to be setting
so this is in the winter Sun our winter
Sun I'll do in a slightly different
color will be setting on the west and
now the apparent direction of that star
is going to be in the direction of the
Sun again but it's going to be shifted
away from Center so it's going to be -
it is going to be to the right of Center
I'm sorry to the left of center so it's
going to be right over here it is going
to be right over here and it's a little
bit unintuitive the way I drew it just
just in the last video well I won't make
any judgement on whether the last one is
easier to visualize or this one is over
here I just wanted to make the
convention so that North is up South is
down but I just want to be clear over
here the Sun is well the Sun always sets
to the west so in the winter the Sun
will be right over there this will be
shifted from Center in the direction of
the Sun so it'll be at an angle at an
angle theta just like that in the winter
now that's all review from the last
video I just reoriented how we visualize
it what I want to do in this video given
that we can measure theta how can we
figure out how far this star actually is
so let's just think about a little bit
before I even give you a theta value
if we know theta then we know we know
what this angle is right over here
because this is a right angle we're
going to know that this angle right here
is 90 minus theta we also know we also
know the distance from the Sun to the
earth and let's say we're just going to
approximate here it's one astronomical
unit it changes a little bit over the
course of the year but the mean distance
is one astronomical unit so how we know
that we know that angle we know side we
know a side adjacent to the angle and
what we're trying to do is figure out a
side opposite to the angle this distance
right here the distance from the Sun to
the star and this is of course a right
triangle and you can see it right here
here is the hypotenuse so now we just
have to break out some relatively basic
trigonometry so if we know this angle
what trig ratio deals with an adjacent
side and an opposite side so let's let
me write down my famous sohcahtoa I
didn't come up with it so the famous
sohcahtoa so Chi Toa sine is opposite
over hypotenuse those aren't the two we
care about cosine is adjacent over
hypotenuse we don't know what the
hypotenuse is and we don't care about it
just yet
but the tangent is the opposite over the
adjacent opposite over the adjacent so
if we take the tangent of the angle if
we take the tangent of 90 minus theta if
we take the tangent of 90 minus theta
this is going to be equal to the
distance to the star this distance right
over here the distance to the star or
the distance from the Sun to the star we
can later figure out the distance from
the earth to the star it's not going to
be too different because the star is so
far away but the distance from the Sun
to the star divided by the adjacent side
divided by one astronomical unit I'm
assuming everything is in astronomical
units so you can multiply both sides by
one and you'll get the distance in
astronomical units the distance is equal
to the tangent of 90 minus theta not too
bad so let's actually figure out what a
distance would be based on some actual
measurements let's say you were to
measure some star measure this apparent
this chain
right here and let's say you got the
total change in angle right over here
from six months apart the biggest spread
and you're making sure you're looking at
a point in the universe relative to
straight up you can do it other ways but
this is really just simplifies our
visualization and simplifies our math
and you get it to be one point five
three seven for arc arc seconds and I
want to be very clear this is a very
very very very very small angle just to
visualize it or another way to think
about it is one point there are 60 arc
seconds per hour committed and there are
60 arc minutes per degree or another way
to think about it as a degree is like an
arc hour so if you want to convert this
to degrees you have 1.5 3 7 4
arc seconds arc seconds times 1 degree
is equal to 3600 arc seconds the
dimensions cancel out and you get this
as being equal to the calculator out
this is being equal to 1.5 3 7 4 divided
by 3600 so it's four point two zero four
point two zero six I'll round because we
only want five significant digits this
is of infinite precision right here
because that's an absolute quantity it's
a definition so let me write this down
so this is going to be this is going to
be four point two seven oh six times ten
to the negative four degrees could write
it just like that now let me be clear
this is the total this is the total
angle this angle that we care about is
going to be half of this so we could
divide this by two so let me just do our
significant digits for point two seven
zero six divided by divided by two or I
could even say times 10 to the negative
four times 10 to the negative four
divided by two is going to be two point
one three five three times ten to the
negative four so that's this angle right
over here this angle or the shift from
Center we could visualize it is going to
be two point one three five three times
ten to the negative four
more so now that we know that we already
figure it out how to figure out the
distance we can just apply this right
over here so let's just take let's just
take the tangent make sure your
calculator is in degree mode I've made
sure of that before I started this video
of 90 - 90 - this angle right here so
instead of retyping I'll just write the
last answer so 90 minus this angle and
we get this large number two hundred
sixty-eight thousand three hundred and
twenty-six now remember what were our
units this distance right here this
distance right here is two hundred and
sixty eight thousand 326 I should just
round because I only have five
significant digits here three hundred
and although with trig trig number with
a trig when you're using involving
trigonometry the significant digits get
a little bit a shade here but I'll just
write the whole number here three three
two hundred sixty eight thousand three
hundred and twenty two hundred sixty
eight thousand three hundred twenty-six
astronomic units so it's this many it's
this many distances between the Sun and
the earth now if we wanted to calculate
that into into light-years we just have
to know and you could calculate this
multiple ways you could just figure out
how far an au is versus a Lightyear but
there are so this is a use there are one
or one light year one light year is
equivalent to sixty 3115 astronomical
units give or take a little bit so this
is going to be equal to the aus cancel
out this quantity divided by that
quantity in lightyears so let's do that
so let's take this number that we just
got divided by sixty three thousand one
hundred fifteen and we have it in
lightyears and so it's about four point
two five light-years I'm messing with
the significant digits here but just
roundabout answer four point two five
light-years four point two five
lightyears four point two five
light-years now remember that's about
how far the closest star to the earth is
and so the closest star to the earth has
this very very very
area parent a very small change in angle
you can imagine as you go to further and
further stars from this that angle this
angle right here is going to get even
smaller and smaller and smaller than all
the way until you get really far stars
and it would be even with our best
instruments you won't be able to measure
that angle anyway hopefully you found
that cool because you just figured out a
way to use trigonometry and a really
good way to measure angles and the night
skies do in the night sky to actually
figure out how far we are from the
nearest stars I think that's that's
pretty neat